[Music]
you seem hardly to have aged at all
really one never discusses a woman's age
Michael would have hoped I taught you
better
oh my gosh that's a clip from sequel to
the 1964 film classic this time starring
Emily Blunt and men Manuel Miranda it
premieres on December 18th and it's one
of the many big films opening this fall
movie season and here to tell us what's
worth watching is Matt singer
editor-in-chief of the website screen
crush dot-com that bet you didn't expect
it why are we all talking the third
remake of a star is born we'll start
there yes is it worth it well give up to
it yeah there there have been this is
the fourth version of the star is born
but it's been 40 years since the last
one with Kris Kristofferson has it been
40 oh you just knocked me down I'm sorry
so it's a new story to them you have
Lady gaga playing this aspiring singer
and Bradley Cooper is this fading rock
star and you know I would love to make a
bad romance joke here but by all
accounts it's it's really good these
little guys people who've seen it so far
they say Lady Gaga is great Bradley
Cooper's great he learned how to sing
you learn how to play the guitar for
them anything now well the first single
for the movie is out shallow and it's
already like number one on the iTunes
app it's a good song all right next up
is the film I'm most looking forward to
which is comes from la-la-land director
Damien Chazelle who I love and he's
again with Ryan Gosling first man about
Neil Armstrong yes the good news is I've
seen this one and it is really good so I
think you're gonna enjoy it this is the
other really big Oscar movie from the
early fall checks off a lot of the boxes
Oscar voters like it is based on this
incredible story and it has Ryan Gosling
a famous actor playing a famous person
it is a departure for Damien Chazelle
he's known for musicals and this is not
a musical there's no songs Neil
Armstrong doesn't seem to fly me to the
moon all these
but it is an incredible movie if you can
see it in IMAX see it and IMAX they shot
the moon stuff spoiler alert they may
but if you can see it in IMAX
it is absolutely sensational alright can
you ever forgive me this is the Melissa
McCarthy movie it's based on a true life
story on Lee Israel a journalist tell us
about it yeah amazing true story
Lee is real Melissa McCarthy plays her
this woman the struggling writers and to
make ends meet she turned to forgery she
started forging letters from famous
literary figures and then selling them
so not your typical I think you can see
just from looking at the clips not your
typical Melissa but this movie dark a
little darker but it has like 23 reviews
on Rotten Tomatoes so far all of them
positive and pretty much everyone's
saying it's like the best performance of
Melissa McCarthy's career so maybe a
little Awards buzz about that one as
well
Wow horror fans they got Halloween the
next the next batch what is it nine ten
this is the eleventh Halloween the
reason to be excited for this one and
there have been a lot there's been 11 I
think and not all of them were worth
being excited for is Jamie Lee Curtis is
back for the first time in like 15 years
great director David Gordon greens and a
lot of good movies and John Carpenter
the director of the original the the
classic Halloween
he returned to do the score his classic
score he kind of came back and made a
new version of the creepy Spore so kind
of the best of the old and the best of
the new Rocky is back to so to see Creed
to so this would be like Rocky 7 or 8 I
think it's 8 yes well tap the chat
that's a Cuellar in the sequel series
yeah the sequel in the sequel series I
loved I loved Creed I thought it was
great now the director of the first one
wine cooler did not come back for this
one but you have Michael B Jordan as
Adonis Creed you have Tessa Thompson you
have Sylvester Stallone back once again
he co-wrote it and you have Dolph
Lundgren returning for the first rocky
for as Ivan Drago I must break you I
think you see him right there he his son
is now a boxer and so you have things
like the family store is going to be
settled by the science just classic
rocky stuff I can't wait and quickly
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald
yeah the first fantastic beasts that
seemed to be more like they tried to
make a standalone movie in the hair
Potter franchise it was did well but it
didn't do Harry Potter well it made less
money than any of the Harry Potter
movies I think now they're going no this
is really like a Harry Potter movie Jude
Law plays the young Dumbledore and I
think they're trying to convince people
you have to see this one to know the
story so much to see Matt singer thank
you so much